[Music]
for this reason it must be said that
nothing is known that is not
inexperience or as it is also expressed
that is not felt to be true not given as
an inwardly revealed Eternal Verity as
something sacred that is believed or
whatever other Expressions have been
used for experiences just this that the
content which is spirit is in itself
substance and therefore an object of
consciousness
but this substance which is spirit is
the process in which Spirit becomes what
it is in itself and it is only as this
process of reflecting into itself that
it is in itself truly spirit
it is in itself the movement which is
cognition the transforming of that in
itself into that which is for itself of
substance into subject of the object of
Consciousness into an object of
self-consciousness that is into an
object that is just as much superseded
or into the notion
the movement is the circle that returns
into itself the circle that presupposes
its beginning and reaches it only at the
end hence so far as spirit is
necessarily this imminent
differentiation its intuited whole
appears over against its simple
self-consciousness and since then the
former is what is differentiated it is
differentiated into its intuitive pure
notion into time and into the content or
into the in itself
substance is charged as subject with the
at first only inward necessity of
setting forth within itself what it is
in itself of exhibiting itself as spirit
only when the objective presentation is
complete is it at the same time the
reflection of substance or the process
in which substance becomes self
consequently until Spirit has completed
itself in itself until it has completed
itself as World spirit
it cannot reach its consummation as
self-conscious spirit
therefore the content of religion
proclaims earlier in time than does
science what spirit is but only science
is its true knowledge of itself
paragraph 802 begins in a very
interesting way with a term that we
haven't seen Hegel using an awful lot
throughout the phenomenology and that is
experience or ifarong and just to go on
a little bit of a digression you know
phenomenology doesn't always mean
exactly the same thing so sometimes
people get mixed up saying you know we
should put the three H's together Hegel
husrell Heidegger because they're all
doing phenomenology well we don't want
to get
uh too mixed up about the ways in which
they're actually doing what they
conceive of as phenomenology and with
you know later 20th century
phenomenology we will certainly see a
big emphasis on looking to our
experience are oftentimes talked about
is lived experience
now Hegel is bringing this up but he's
bringing it up as kind of a starting
point so I mean you could say in very
broad Strokes he's not saying this here
that
we really do need to experience in some
sense
Spirit but what we're experiencing
is something that is going to be
transformed as as we're going to see and
he's beginning here by using a following
as a as I just mentioned a starting
point for these reflections
explaining what it is that you know when
we're engaging in time as we've seen
it's very important right and the next
paragraph we're actually going to start
talking about
human history so time implicitly
includes that and you know we can also
talk about individuality or
particularity and we can talk about
actuality the actual World vehicle kite
those All Connect up with experience
don't they so he is going to talk about
expressing experience in several
different ways and
each of these
is you could say
a lesser mode of
knowing or perhaps not even knowing you
know for example felt to be true gefuth
of our height right
um the truth that is grasped through the
mediation of feeling
um you know for Hegel that's kind of a
low level of of uh grasping something
it's not as good as it's not as adequate
as understanding or representation let
alone the concept or notion the Crypt
right
but you know it's not as if it's nothing
whatsoever and you know feelings are
indeed a significant part of our
experience
he also talks about the inwardly
revealed
Eternal reality and
this could mean a lot of different
things you know bringing up Eternal
reality takes us all the way back to the
unhappy Consciousness where the area the
Eternal comes in uh is something that
we're trying to reach out to and not
grasping that we ourselves are
projecting it way out there right but
now inwardly revealed so it's no longer
just the unhappy Consciousness it's
within
Us in in our experience and then he
talks about the sacred the High Legos
The Holy if you want to that is believed
in uh get out right and you notice
there's a lot of
terms here that should remind us of not
just the religion section but the
previous forms of religion in here so
let's look at what he says for this
reason it must be said that nothing is
known right so we've got vicen at play
here that is not in experience so when
things are inexperienced we're going to
see Hegel talking about a term he's used
a lot in this in halt content right so
the things that are the content or we
might say the object the geagenstein of
experience
so
things are known through experience and
he says you know that it's not felt to
be true and or given as an inwardly
revealed Eternal Verity as something
sacred that is believed or whatever
other Expressions have been used so he's
not saying
um these are the only things that we
could possibly
use as stand in for experience so I mean
this opens up a wide range of
possibilities we could talk about not
just the experience of the religious but
of being part of a community being
engaged in the quest to find the truly
moral comportment or or action right all
those could be part of our experience in
this now this is as I mentioned just
going to be the starting point because
he says
for experience is just this that the
content which is Spirit Geist
is in itself
substance
he's going to use this word substance
here a number of times he's used it in
the previous paragraphs substance is
less developed less
capable of agency and reflection than is
a subject or a self or Spirit or in this
case two science
so
in a Cell substance and therefore an
object of Consciousness Consciousness
human consciousness as Spirit grasps
substance whatever that substance
happens to be could be the uh you know
stuff in the the Consciousness section
the objects of immediate seemingly
immediate but very highly mediated
um you know uh sense perception the
thing and its qualities the different
qualities themselves uh force and the
understanding laws worlds all these
sorts of things and then the subject has
to realize its own involvement in this
so he goes on and he says
this substance which is Spirit okay so
substance isn't just something inert
is the process now a process here is
translating viaden literally becoming
bad translation
um
Miller's going to use this term process
a couple times
but then he's also going to use the word
becomes so it can be a little bit
confusing so there is a becoming there
is a transition a moving from one
state to another or you know a greater
unfolding or development so he goes on
he says
um
this substance which is spirit is the
process in which
Spirit now no longer just substance
becomes what it is in itself
and it is only as this process of
reflecting reflectiran itself into
itself that it is in itself truly Spirit
a lot of itself's there right
but this is a really important truth
spirit that merely takes the world or
the processes or even in the way in
which a lot of people think of science
the objects of science for granted and
doesn't
comprehend through the the conscious
subject or the self-conscious subject
what its own involvement is is not
getting the full picture is actually as
we saw in the previous paragraph
in revealing there's also concealing
so at this point in the game
Spirits you and me and the
phenomenologist that is Hegel
ought to be further along
we might say right
so going on a little bit further
he says it is in itself the movement the
vivegong which is cognition air kentness
now notice I've got vicen and we've got
air kentness both of which were used in
the previous paragraph cognition is not
yet knowing let alone uh beguyphenus uh
you know be gracefully his conceptual
knowing that we want right here but uh
cognition is going to be a set of what
Hegel is going to say
transformings of different things the in
itself
into the four itself
you know always doing this right in in
the hegelian dialectic
but also
substance into
subject we'll come back to that in just
a minute because that's that's quite
important
and then
getting a little bit more complex the
object the gagenstrand what it is that
is presented to it against it right
of Consciousness transforming that into
the object of
self-consciousness
now that requires some explanation as
well
but notice that there's one more thing
that's being added here
that means as he's going to say Das
Heist I.E into an object that is just as
much even zul
superseded
Alpha hobnen gegenstein right so we've
got object four Consciousness or the
object of Consciousness the object of
self-consciousness then we have the
object superseded and this is what the
object of self-consciousness is raised
to a higher level what is essential in
it encapsulated what is unessential Left
Behind and what is this this is the
notion the concept the graph right
the object of self-consciousness in this
discussion
is the concept
it you grasp it conceptually and that is
how you are a self-consciousness you're
not self-consciousness just by relating
yourself to another self-consciousness
as we saw way way back when you're not
self-consciousness by Desiring
recognition from the other
self-consciousness that that's part of
it right but that is what has to be of
cohobeness that or you know raised to a
higher level uh superseded sublated
right transformed well-being
Incorporated so we have here this
interplay moving from just being
conscious of an object to being
conscious of ourselves as conscious of
the object as grasping the object as
being involved in this process and
thereby having
notional or conceptual
grasp of the substance the object and we
can see at this point what the hell is
the substance here well we're going to
get to that well let's come back to
thinking about what it means to be
transformed into
a subject or as he's going to say a
little bit later a self
so what is a subject we have talked
about this before in the commentary when
we contrasted these different s's
substance self Spirit
um subject so a subject is able to take
stances comportments towards other
things as Consciousness that has objects
as self-consciousness that has objects
in a richer way right
so the subject if substance is being
transformed into subject
it has to become aware of its very own
self and this is part of what spirits
indeed is Spirit this entire
dialectic and what is driving it what
its substance at first is and then later
subject and self will be
is something that relates itself to
other things and also to itself in that
process getting to know itself
come back to the experience that we seem
to have left behind
you know hagel's not saying this here
but we could read that in and say this
is the experience of spirit is it not so
he goes on
and he tells us
the movement is the circle that returns
into itself now you know this is where
people start talking about the uriburos
you know the snake that's swallowing its
own tail and all that sort of stuff and
they're like oh this is so cool
sometimes they're like oh very mystical
and stuff like that and I think Hegel in
this presentation uh on his own part can
be a bit misleading because what we're
not talking about here is starting at
Point a going around the circle and
winding back at Point a or endless
repetition in Cycles
transformation is taking place and
you're not arriving just back at Point a
but point a
transformed point a reconnected with the
rest of the circle point a that is
conscious of itself as having
developed more this is very very
important you should not lose sight of
this in this language about circles as a
matter of fact I much prefer thinking in
terms of spiral spiraling in on on
something or you know a circle that
becomes
more developed as it goes on anyway he
says
um the movement is a circle that returns
into itself the circle that presupposes
its beginning and reaches it only at the
end so we don't have like cycle after
cycle we have one Circle here right
one go around
and it's a big big go-around so it
comprises like this entire work we're
not quite there yet and it would
presumably
involve uh human history and the
development of Consciousness over time
through all these different shapes of
Consciousness that Hegel has charted out
for us at this this point
all right so going on
says hence in so far spirit is
necessarily
this imminent differentiation now we saw
the discussion about
differentiation in the previous
paragraph right so we've got we've got
two things going on
we've got all this
differentiation
um
imposing distinctions dividing is
another way of talking about it and
we're also going to have this process of
completion or consummation so we've got
you know winter scheiden and we've got
uh folendum or you know all sorts of
verbal uh
compositions of this as well and these
are connected to each other
spirit is necessarily this imminent
differentiation it's it's you know
broken into a bunch of different things
it's intuited whole we saw a whole or
totality in the last paragraph being
brought up as a key part of this as well
appears over against its simple
self-consciousness yeah we saw you know
self-consciousness again just in
previous paragraphs individual
self-consciousness Universal
self-consciousness self-consciousness of
the knowing person at this point in the
phenomenology is both of these together
and it's sort of like a composite
picture of what the subject or the self
is
so
um since then
the former what is the former the
intuited whole
is what is differentiated it is
differentiated into its intuited pure
notion into time pure notion pure
concept and we saw this being brought up
as well right that was sort of a middle
point
um before that we had the pure notion
and then we had time as this
differentiation that's that's taking
place
um so
it's intuited pure notion into time uh
and into the content or into the in
itself so the intuitive pure notion is
itself differentiated we could say along
the lines of time and through time and
by time and yet it's more than just time
this is where we're going to get to
history a little bit later but it's also
a
completion or a consummation a full
ending as we're going to see right
so he goes on and and says that
substance is charged so substance is
transforming into subject it is charged
as subject with the at first only inward
necessity a necessity that has to be
brought to light
of setting forth within itself what it
is in itself of exhibiting itself as
spirit
now it sounds like we've got a further
task to do but this is something that
Spirit has been doing this entire time
it's just not completely finished yet
or maybe it is finished and now we're
just realizing that it's finished
according to Hegel so he says only when
the objective presentation is complete
now complete here is volendita
so what is it to be completed in this
sense to be brought to all of its
potential to be transformed into its
highest most developed and also most
conscious state that it can reach
and it turns out you know I mean some
things
this piece of chalk
not a lot of potential in that sense in
this I mean it can be used to discuss
Consciousness but it's not conscious and
I can be conscious of it I can use it as
an as a tool uh the book
uh you know
insofar as object
basically like a piece of truck insofar
as containing the mind of somebody
called Hegel maybe there's more going on
there right it's a sort of record a
compendium that we can engage with now
you and me
we are subject our self our spirit our
mind can be brought to a much much
higher level and we can do so much more
when we think conceptually which means
thinking as self-consciousness which
partly takes itself as its own object
and other self-consciousnesses and not
just the other self-consciousness over
there but those that we've seen in in
time the ones that led us up to this
point so objective presentation
right objective
um well we've got we've got here the
object of Consciousness the object of
self-consciousness that's what he's
talking about this transformation and
then presentation is darsh Delong not
for stellen putting putting it out there
um presenting it right so that is what
has to be completed when the objective
presentation is complete only then is it
at the same time the reflection of
substance or the process the viadin in
which substance becomes here he says
self
self and subject here really two ways of
talking about the same thing
so that's what we're doing that's what
Hegel thinks has happened now for spirit
and we can reap the benefits of it so to
speak we're getting to this you know
final end point of the history of human
consciousness developing which just
happens to finish up with Hegel himself
very convenient you might say but also
Hegel thinks absolutely necessary
there is an epistemological
grounding that's happening here
right and this is something we've
discussed in the past so let's let's
dwell on this a moment
um Hegel thinks
very clearly
that you know the meaning of History
is to be found after history has
essentially finished up its processes of
development and spirit can Look
Backwards at it that's what the
phenomenologist is doing and see all the
different developmental shapes or stages
and how they led to each other through a
kind of necessity not a logical
necessity not a mathematical necessity
but a this uh had to somewhere lead to
this happening and this is a Superior
State and so that it goes on from there
so he says
until Spirit has completed itself in
itself until it has completed itself now
he introduces this as World Spirit now
we're going to talk about history again
and you know the coming paragraphs and
Hegel has you know lectures on world
history and all that we could go into
that later
World spirits
when you're seeing the world Spirit here
think of the spirit of a totality a Gods
the whole
but in time
right the whole world
doesn't mean every part in the world is
actually as connected with her
exemplifying spirit as much but
somewhere Spirit has to be doing this
just so happens that it's in Europe and
you know very conveniently for Hegel
again
um in in the you know Western Europe
England France Germany and mostly in
Germany right where he happens to be
doing his uh his work at the time so uh
he says
it cannot reach its consummation it's
its finality it's
um being brought to its its highest
state as self-conscious Spirit
therefore the content of religion so all
these things that we're talking about
with efarong or experience
proclaims earlier in time
than does science what spirit is
but there's a superiority that's science
Vision shaft which works with Concepts
and not just representations
has over religion religion is like
philosophy just not as fully
self-conscious not as fully developed as
science which is what Hegel views
himself as doing through his philosophy
as science is and so religion is great
actually art is also going to be great
you know you notice that in the
phenomenology art got rolled into
religion and later works Hagel will have
both religion and art is like leading up
to philosophy and not just any old
philosophy but dialectical philosophy
right because there's also philosophy of
the understanding a whole whole other
topic there so he says the content of
religion the inhalt what we experience
we get that earlier in time then we get
genuine this and shaft or science uh
science is Spirits true knowledge of
itself you might say oh that's not how I
understand science
probably not because we live in a time
in which we tend to think of science
much more in terms of being what it is
that we study and then we have things
for the object of Consciousness or
perhaps the object of self-consciousness
you know we study psychology as opposed
to say biology and you know with
psychology it's a little bit easier for
us to say oh this does apply to me right
but Hegel is saying this has to apply to
the totality
of human development
that's what genuine vissenshaft in the
full sense
is going to
be and provide us with so we have some
pretty important Transformations here
now I think we can actually again
outside of the text I think we can
actually ask an important question here
so you know he's talking about having
reached
a certain State having completed things
let's grant that
we do have to have like gone along the
way and we can talk about least complete
perhaps with you know sense certainty
and then more and more and more and more
complete can't we with religion itself
being a whole uh set of you know this is
more complete this is more complete this
is more complete
Hegel is saying until you actually get
to the end
you where things are complete you can't
adequately
judge how complete
each stage is and there's something to
that you know each of the stages that
we've gone through presents itself to us
as if it is the final stage and you know
we get used to this through reading the
phenomenology we're like oh you know it
looks like we're done here and then
hagel's like oh that's not the case and
sometimes it's like let's move on to the
next slab section you know let's
introduce a couple intro interesting
ideas to to Grapple with and sometimes
it's like we're going to move from
reason to Spirit or Spirit to religion a
whole new portion of the phenomenology
and I suppose you could say that the
breaks between reason and
um Spirit or self-consciousness and
reason or uh spirit and religion are not
as big of a jump as from the
Consciousness to the self-consciousness
section that is that is a a significant
rupture there but we can we can grasp
um why it had to be that way according
to Hegel
at the end which is
where we are now
we only have you know we're in paragraph
802 there's only 808 paragraphs in the
whole work so we only have six more
paragraphs to go to finish this up to
you know
see entirely what we're supposed to have
been brought to the edge to look over
I mean also to look back
and understand
so you know there's there's quite a lot
going on here as I mentioned he isn't
yet talking about
um history yet he's talking about time
but we're going to get into history
right in the next paragraph early on so
you can start anticipating
that from where we're sitting as we go
through this this paragraph and the role
that experience cognition knowledge then
finally science
play in this entire process
of development of Distinction and then
the completion of spirit